if efendim is here artist driver Sascha
finds himself in an old quarry in the
mountains the perfect setting to test an
SUV
although Sascha says that SUVs aren't
necessarily built to drive on this kind
of terrain that's why we're hitting the
road to put today's car through its
paces it's the second generation Ford
Kuga it hits in fun we tested a model
with a 2-liter diesel engine and 120
kilowatts of power the four-wheel-drive
version costs thirty-two thousand euros
in Germany this is the most popular of
the diesel models the powerful
4-cylinder turbo engine drives the car
forward creating 340 Newton meters of
torque the Kouga can reach a speed of
100 km/h and 9.9 seconds with a top
speed of 198 km/h nothing out of the
ordinary for this type of car
meet Sara Sasha says the diesel engine
is very powerful as he expected the
handling on the second-generation model
is satisfactory too of course the co2
emissions aren't great the Kouga gives
off 154 grams of co2 per kilometer
but as sasha says anyone who wants a
more environmentally friendly car would
obviously buy something smaller to get
around with anyway ford has introduced
several new safety features up to 12
driver assistance systems can be
requested from a lane assistant with a
driver fatigue detector to the active
City stop system and parking guides
the omnium Fox ashes in the driver's
seat and says there are a lot of buttons
on the dashboard but he says anyone
interested in buying the car will have
tried them all out and know what they
all do and anyway during the journey
you'll only need to use a few of them so
they're only a little distracting
blinking often with a Latif course I'm
right another small criticism sasha has
is that the display of the sat-nav is
smaller than the display on his
cellphone he thinks that Ford should
make it bigger so that it's easier to
read and causes less confusion for the
driver the Cougars design is simple and
elegant the lines give the compact SUV a
sporty and robust appearance the
contours of the hood are stronger than
on the first generation model
the new Kouga is 8 centimeters longer 8
millimeters lower and four millimeters
slimmer than its predecessor which makes
it more spacious and less wind resistant
is in yes Sasha is looking at the
different pillars on the car he says
that while most of them won't affect the
drivers vision too much but at the rear
windscreen it's another matter
Sasha points to the area where the
drivers feel the vision begins to the
right of that the glass is black that
means there's a blind spot and Sasha
says a driver wouldn't be able to see
children shorter than 1.2 meters
standing there but hopefully the parking
sensors wouldn't pick them up or the
driver would see them in the rear view
camera
Sasha then shows us how you can open the
trunk without getting your hands dirty
the sensor under the car pops it open
automatically that sensor costs a bit
extra though Sasha says the extra 8
centimeters in back seat legroom are
really noticeable both front seats are
all the way back and he still has a good
12 centimeters of room the back seats
can be folded over as well if the back
seats are folded completely the space in
the trunk goes up from 481 litres - 1653
liters mine faucets so Sasha's verdict
on the 2nd generation Ford Kuga he says
the facelift is an improvement it's more
angular masculine and concise the 120
kilowatt diesel engine isn't the best
for the environment but for people who
will be carrying heavy loads might need
the power if you're looking for a more
ecologically friendly model then go for
something smaller or maybe one of the
petrol models you can save some money
that way as well